good to see all of you together again i
feel like you're never not together
though
right like you guys
we have a big car we just traveled
yeah
mary i wanted to ask you you know
i know a lot of families watch this show
together season after season when you
get caught in the street by cobra kai
fans who was more excited the adults or
the kids
oh
that's tough i mean i feel like it's the
great thing like you said about the show
is that it is kind of across the board
we have you know such such a reach with
uh with our audience which is awesome i
will say that most the time though it's
the adults who are willing to ask for a
picture the teens are usually the ones
who are like
and it's like i was that one too like
and my mom would be like oh just go ask
my mom if you know me so like i get a
lot of the parents they're like my kid
won't say this but they really want to
take a picture with you um but i think
it's i think that's the cool thing about
the show is that you know a lot of times
i'll get the i was super into the karate
kid and now i get to share this with my
kids and the kids being like yeah yeah
whatever anyway so it's super cool
getting to see you guys punch and beat
each other up but uh but no i think i
think
i will say the the parents are a lot
braver
that's awesome you know one of the great
things about following the show again
season after season you really never
know
where people are going to go what size
they're going to choose what's going to
happen next peyton is it super exciting
to see
tory be such a central part of uh of
this season
yeah yeah it definitely is and
i mean speaking of loyalty to dojo's i
do love how loyal uh tori has been
consistently to cobra kai
yeah
she's just like no yeah no not give me
any way you know it's it's funny talking
about like spoilers because you guys are
already i'm assuming you know what's
going to come next the next season while
we're all watching the previous season
is it difficult like jacob i see you
smiling is it difficult for you to keep
those secrets under your hat like is
there someone in your life who's like yo
i will cook you a nice dinner just tell
me what's going on season 6.
no i laugh because i just know i'm
winning the next tournament as well
uh noah last
last season i think was the hardest um
because while we were doing promos for
season four we were in the middle of
filming season five and so i would start
to say something about season five it's
like
so far in the future for the people
interviewing us yeah um that's that's
been really hard but i'm you know what's
funny most of the time when i meet
people or a lot of my friends who watch
the show they're like don't talk about
it i don't want to know
anything because they're like really
invested i'm like all right yeah okay
and it was a scandal a scandal i'm
telling you
amazing show what's it been like
watching the ogs all back together like
seeing them rehearse seeing them
practice their moves together getting
ready for those fight scenes like what's
the experience
they're really cute they're all really
cute it's funny seeing them uh you know
they they definitely put in the hours
when it comes to their rehearsals and
stuff like that it's really impressive
how these guys you know all these years
after the original are still able to to
get their
kicks really high but it doesn't come
without a little competition they
definitely are competitive on set when
they're both when they're both filming
together you can you can tell a little
bit that they're like nice oh one of
them will mess with moving
what's their reaction when you say
things to them like all these years like
after all these years
it's great to see that they're all like
their legs up there get fired
i mean they say it themselves are you
kidding no they're they're the first
ones to admit that it's that it's
impressive and if anything it's it's uh
it's a spectacle they they should be
awesome it's a spectacle that they can
boom i guess
no dude it's hard for us to do it
it's hard for us to do it well guys
i gotta say season five was an absolute
blast to watch and yeah we don't want to
give anything away uh thanks so much for
the time we'll see you next time
you